the gops reversal of fortune that's the
focus of tonight's angle just three
months ago three reputable polls had the
Democrats up at least 15 points in the
generic congressional ballot well not
anymore
Reuters latest generic ballot poll
should hearten Republicans at the
beginning of March Democrats enjoyed
more than a ten-point advantage nearly
45 percent saying that vote for a damn
well only 33% would pull the lever for
Republican but now the GOP has taken the
lead the latest online poll shows 39
percent of registered voters saying they
would vote Republican and just thirty
six point seven percent supporting a
Democrat six point shift so why is this
turnaround happening because Republicans
pretty much staying on offense and
supporting generally not undermining the
president on key issues by working to
keep this economy going dismantling the
regulatory super state that hurts our
innovators and entrepreneurs by not
dragging us into more serious military
conflicts by refusing to buckle on
immigration at least so far the GOP is
actually gaining momentum according to
the cook Political Report California's
39th and 49th districts have both
shifted from lean Democratic to toss-up
Nebraska's second district moved from
toss-up to lean Republican at South
Carolina's fifth district moved from
likely Republican to solid Republican so
as you can imagine this has thrown the
Democrats into a full-on frothy panic
the party of failed ideas has issued a
new anti-corruption message that's gonna
be what drives the midterms for them and
they hope it's gonna breed them success
now it's been said that imitation is the
sincerest form of flattery so I wonder
what plagiarism gets you hmm
Democratic leaders and a new memo kind
of seemed to be channeling Trump they're
writing this the American people are
sick of getting a raw deal from
Washington well if this all sounds vague
familiar it is the people got a raw deal
and they deserve so much better
government's being eaten alive cronyism
and kicked the crooks out of Washington
DC now if you can't beat him
repeat him I guess well there is a few
major problems with the Democrats
adopting an anti-corruption platform
because they are the party of corruption
these are the people that brought you
Obama's weaponized IRS the targeted
Conservatives years ago
same party the circled the wagons around
Hillary Clinton's paid a place game at
the State Department where Blackberry
phones were smashed and hard drives were
erased by bleach pit oh let's not forget
the party of debbie Wasserman Schultz
who while running the DNC employed an IT
specialist who tried to flee to Pakistan
after rewired money their money federal
prosecutors say was obtained illegally
number of federal grand jury indicted
him and his wife on four counts last
summer bank fraud and conspiracy charges
and this is the party by the way that's
going to root out corruption oh the
Clintons and their political spawn are
so unscrupulous that supporters of
Bernie Sanders filed the class-action
lawsuit against the DNC for rigging the
primaries in Hillary's favor don't you
get that an air of desperation has begun
to settle over the Democrats because
they thought they were guaranteed to
strike electoral gold in November
congressman Al Green he's a Texas dem is
promising that if they take control of
the house quote there's a good
likelihood there will be articles of
impeachment brought against the
president that's it that's your plan oh
oh how's that going to grow voters 401
k's or keep our manufacturing boom going
impeachment is not a pro-growth platform
kids and if that doesn't get out the
vote well some liberal foot soldiers
hope that attempts at comedy will Deputy
Chair of the Democratic National
Committee congressman keith Ellison he
donned a blonde wig to impersonate the
president recently
warning cover your pets ears and put
masking tape on the windowpanes he will
not be seen in Hamilton anytime soon
tunas flat is its flat off kids address
the Democratic message my friends this
should be fairly easy for the
Republicans there's a great sense of
optimism in the country it's a great
time to be an American I think there's
no better time than maybe in the 80s
during Reagan's so it's time to double
down on the accomplishments support the
president's populist pro-growth agenda
the GOP at the same time must also avoid
any self-inflicted wounds before the
midterms promoting or passing an amnesty
plan on going weak on China that could
actually dishearten the base it could
break faith with the blue-collar workers
who swept the president and the GOP into
office and could again if you stand with
them and that's the angle